[Music]
Glass Onion a Knives Out mystery has
even more layers to peel back than its
predecessor but Kentucky Fried detective
Benoit Blanc doesn't provide all the
answers by the time the credits roll as
the pieces of the puzzle come together
it's revealed that Andy not miles was
the Keystone of this friend group whose
connection dates back to their young
adulthood in fact miles was the annoying
awkward Outcast who is late to join the
group at the Glass Onion bar Andy's
stamp of approval is what gained a
person admittance into the club so Miles
doesn't just have Andy to thank for the
idea he stole he owes his entire social
life to her what's more he isn't the
only one in a flashback Glass Onion
shows that Miles with Andy's okay
enabled this morally pliable group of
Misfits to reach for the stars and it
worked birdie Jay became a Covergirl and
fashion designer Claire became a
governor Lionel became a top scientist
and Duke became a YouTube celebrity but
how did they do it was it just money and
influence were their careers just bought
and paid for or were miles and dandy
actively managing their careers and
feeding them ideas after Andy's death
they're all floundering Lionel is
starting to suspect that eccentric
billionaire miles is actually an idiot
birdies in over her head producing her
apparel line Claire is beholden to her
dark money campaign funders without Andy
keeping them honest and on track her
disrupter friends are shown to be merely
incompetent if not corrupt the
infighting and paranoia between this
closed circle of friends could be traced
back to a single napkin from the Glass
Onion bar upon which Andy had scribbled
ideas for a tech startup Andy and Miles
went on to found that company together
and their joint venture grew into
something so lucrative and Broad in
scope it's experimenting with a new kind
of renewable energy called clear
arguments over whether to take clear to
Market caused the rift between Andy and
Miles Andy could see that it was too
dangerous and unstable in its current
form and could bring down their business
if not the world when Andy wants out who
possesses the napkin and what exactly is
written on it becomes a life or death
legal issue Glass Onion provides closure
to that mystery but it doesn't tell us
much about what Andy miles and their
company originally did the closest we
get is Jake Tapper on CNN hinting that
Alpha ultimately became a blend of
SpaceX Tesla and Amazon with an alpha
News network attached ubiquity this Tech
Giant Alpha which now has dozens of
companies from alpha Cosmos Alpha Car
Alpha it's not essential to the plot for
viewers to know but in an age when
Silicon Valley CEOs believe themselves
capable of anything it would have been
fun to find out about Andy's Innovations
and how they really made their fortunes
starting out we meet birdie Jay when
everyone is supposed to be social
distancing birdie however is throwing a
crowded glitzy party with her alleged
pod Sons any coveted mitigations
whatsoever she is coded as a
self-absorbed superficial socialite who
considers herself to be above the law
birdie is all those things and for much
of glass onions run time viewers are
left to wonder if she might be capable
of murder too but as it turns out her
biggest crime is that she just isn't
smart enough to run a fashion label
relatively early on Miles lets Peg know
that birdie's in his debt and he expects
her to take the fall for some Scandal
the real Scandal is Andy's murder but
there's also the matter of for clothing
line which uses inhumane labor practices
and slave wages to keep profits high
this information is about to go public
and rather than have both of their
reputations take the hit miles wants
birdie to assume full responsibility she
is to blame but not necessarily because
she's an evil capitalist what a
corporate memo warned the factory they
were about to subcontract was a
sweatshop birdie J misunderstood this
please tell me you did not think
sweatshops
are where they make
sweatpants miles had birdie all but
convinced to confess to the Press but
with those police boats approaching it's
unclear if birdie still plans to come
clean or if she'll pin her mistake on
the murderer from the moment Bertie J
receives her invitation to the moment
the police arrive via boat at the film's
end put upon Peg is there helping her
rich and famous boss to function she's
just as invested in the Sweatshop
debacle because if birdie goes down she
loses her job while the audience doesn't
know how much Peg makes or how well
birdie Jay treats her it seems like the
gig comes with perks like a trip to
Greece and frustrations like having to
explain what a sweatshop is to an adult
who happens to be your Superior
flamboyant Life of the Party birdie is
probably fun to be around though there's
an obvious class difference between them
birdie does seem to appreciate Peg and
she's never shown to act with outright
cruelty to order being the personal
assistant to a b-list celebrity wasn't
her dream but it must be fulfilling
enough if she doesn't want the work to
dry up if birdie should get canceled
still from time to time in Glass Onion
Peg looks and sounds as if she's over
this lifestyle and ready to move on and
put her abilities towards something less
frivolous just as it's unknown if birdie
took the fall for the human rights
abusing fashion label it's unknown if
Pegg stuck with her through the murder
mystery weekend's dramatic conclusion
when whiskey first arrives on screen
audiences might assume she's little more
than Duke's most recent fling after all
he's a men's rights activist and there's
a noticeable age difference between the
couple but whiskey is quickly revealed
to be a woman very much in charge of her
own narrative as well as something of a
double agent when she cozies up with
Miles as duke peeps through a bedroom
window seemingly devastated it seems her
true self is emerging but in the wake of
Duke's death it becomes clear that she
and her not so jealous boyfriend were in
cahoots they thought that if whiskey
could seduce miles she could convince
him to promote both of their brands with
his new 24-hour media Enterprise
garnering them more followers while
whiskey is upset that Duke's Dead The
Savvy aspiring influencer is the type of
person who looks out for number one it
would be interesting to see how she
spins the sure to be newsworthy story of
her boyfriend's murder into more star
power
at some point Claire tabella was an
altruistic person who got into politics
for the right reasons the film gives
viewers the sense that in the early days
of her friendship with Andy she was
someone who wanted to affect change and
would have balked at the idea of taking
bribes or voting in favor of special
interests at the expense of the people
she sought to represent you know soccer
mom and beige throwing grenades into
machine politics but campaign Finance
laws are campaign Finance laws and
Governor Clarita Bella is under the
thumbs of her funders namely miles and
the various industries that would stand
profit if Government Regulators give
clear the well all clear from her
anxious kg behavior and her whispered
conversations with Lionel it's apparent
that Claire isn't thrilled to be in this
position she knows clears a disaster
waiting to happen and she knows that the
money she's accepting is Tainted during
the events of Glass Onion she's
currently locked in a tight race for the
United States Senate and if she doesn't
support miles both in getting his energy
source congress's approval and in
staying quiet about the napkin and
Angie's murder he and his cronies will
pull their support of her candidacy
viewers might wonder what would Claire
do as governor or Senator if corrupt
oligarchs weren't pulling her strings
does the arrest of Miles finally free
her to lead and legislate as she truly
would to do that she'd have to win her
election and Glass Onion ends abruptly
without comments Andy split from her
business partner Miles because she
thought he was flying too close to the
Sun with his ambition to make clear a
viable replacement for oil coal and gas
had it truly been viable and you would
have stayed on board but she knew that
the substance wasn't just potentially
deadly but imminently deadly in the
film's opening sequence as the puzzle
box invitations of miles are being
delivered to his invited guests viewers
can tell he's putting intense pressure
on Lionel to have a breakthrough or to
at least make it look like he's had a
breakthrough he confesses as much to
Claire in the pool but it's unclear if
he's motivated by protecting consumers
or his position it seems safe to assume
that Lionel a research scientist is a
smart guy he must realize that even if
his employer strong-arms him into acting
as clear as credibility cover his
reputation will suffer once it shows
itself to be a catastrophic failure at
the end of Glass Onion Lionel seems to
think that Helen has done them all a
favor by exposing miles and his deeply
flawed Discovery but it's unclear
whether the company which is bigger than
miles is put the brakes on the planned
release of their supposedly
game-changing energy product clear could
make an appearance or become a running
joke in future Benoit Blanc Mysteries
the characters in the first Knives Out
are the type of entitled Elites who
aren't accustomed to facing consequences
as the mystery unfolds for the first
time in some of their lives they do but
the hypocritical phonies and
white-collar criminals in Glass Onion
wield more power and influence than the
mere upper class publishing family of
Knives Out miles Brawn in particular
belongs to an entirely different class
of entitled Elite when Helen sits at the
water's edge and sees the red and blue
lights of the police boats blinking it's
implied that miles will pay for his
Crimes by the end of Glass Onion his rap
sheet has gotten longer not only did he
steal Andy's idea he poisoned her and
framed her death as a suicide he killed
Duke via his allergic reaction to his
mixed drink he attempted to kill Helen
he indirectly destroyed the Mona Lisa by
circumventing its security measures he
was also about to launch a product that
would have caused damage and Death on an
Untold scale miles is probably going
away for a long time time even if it
seems likely that after the credits
rolled this Weasley credit Taker and his
retained lawyers attempt every trick in
the book to escape liability
the key to unlocking the mystery at the
center of Glass Onion is The Epiphany
that Janelle Monae is playing dual roles
as identical twin sisters Andy and Helen
brand my name is Helen brand and I came
all the way here from Alabama while Andy
can be seen in flashbacks in the present
timeline every instance in which the
movie makes viewers feel they're
watching Andy they're actually watching
Helen impersonating her dead sister no
small feat for the working class small
town mom while Andy and Helen appear to
have a good sisterly relationship their
paths diverged about as much as twins
lives could power player Andy was a
poised and Polished Globetrotter while
Helen leads an exceedingly normal life
in comfortable clothes with her Regional
accent still intact Benoit Blanc
correctly deduces that bringing Helen
cosplaying as Andy will be the ultimate
disruption to the disruptors murder
mystery Affair though at Great risk to
himself and the imposter's sister they
pull off their scheme thanks to Jeremy
renner's hot sauce Helen's bravery and
the stupidity of Miles presumably Helen
will be able to prove in court that Andy
was the originator of the napkin idea
and that Miles killed her and Duke to
prevent that information from coming out
which raises the question what happens
next for Helen will she inherit some or
all of her late sister's Fortune will
she do something different with her
Newfound notoriety or will she continue
to partner with Blanc now that she's
proven herself to be a Savvy sleuth
[Music]